It's been 25 years since the Hubble launched
and changed how we look at space forever,
but even though it's probably the most famous
-- there are 93 space telescopes out there!
WHAT!?
Hey space cadets, Trace here scoping out the
science for DNews.
In 1610, Galileo took a telescope and pointed
it at Jupiter -- igniting a love for space
that goes far beyond simple naked-eye stargazing.
The ultimate in astral gazing is the space
telescope, an imager not affected by the interference
of stuff here on earth like clouds, weather,
particulates in the atmosphere, or the light
pollution of a nearby city!
The most famous of which, The Hubble Space
Telescope just reached its 25th birthday!!
(blow thing) Happy Birthday, Hubble!
The HST isn't the largest one up there, but
it's versatile, capturing visible and ultraviolet
light with a bit of infrared sensing.
Hubble, orbits 353 miles (569 km) above Earth,
and was designed to be serviced in space by
astronauts; something no other space telescope
has done.
Which is lucky, since it famously needed to
be fixed right after it was launched.
Hubble's final servicing mission in 2009 should
keep it running until 2020, but eventually
it will die -- so what then?
Along comes the James Webb!
The James Webb Space Telescope is Hubble's
successor.
Its mirror is 7 times larger than Hubble's
- the total surface area is the size of a
tennis court!
But while it's the follow-up to the HST, it's
not identical.
It captures mainly infrared light, because
its larger mirror is designed to look WAY
farther into the universe -- and the farther
things get away, the more redshifted they
are.
Redshifting is the tendency for the light
of distant objects to elongate -- or shift
toward the redder end of the light spectrum.
To look far away, we need an infrared telescope!
The James Webb will also be even FARTHER from
Earth -- orbiting at LaGrange point 2.
A LaGrange point is a spot in space where
gravity from the moon and the Earth balance
-- like a gravitational parking spot!
L2 is actually out PAST the moon!
It's the perfect spot for a telescope -- like
Planck, which is already there.
See, we're only looking at a tiny part of
the picture with Webb and Hubble; infrared,
ultraviolet, and visible light.
We've got way shorter and way longer.
Infrared is longer than visible, and microwaves
are longer than infrared!
Microwave telescopes scan the microwaves coming
out of stars, but more importantly, the bubble
of microwave radiation which exploded from
the Big Bang.
The European Space Agency's Planck satellite
was launched in 2009 with the goal of imaging
that bubble of microwave radiation which surrounds
our whole universe: called the Cosmic Microwave
Background radiation.
This bubble is 13.7 billion year-old energy;
and can tell us a lot about the birth of our
universe.
The ESA says, Planck is so advanced, it will
take measurements which cannot be improved
on with any future telescopes.
But that's not all for long waves.
In 2011, Spektr-R was launched by Russia to
look at the last wider band of the EM spectrum,
radio.
The Spektr-R has a 10 meter (33ft) radio telescope
to observe the structure of galaxies, star
formations, black holes, dark matter and interstellar
space -- things we can't pick up with the
nearer visible spectrum.
Because these waves are so long, the Spektr-R
works with ground-based telescopes to pick
up as much of the radio signals as possible!
As far as shorter wave telescopes, the Chandra
X-Ray Space Observatory was launched in 1999,
and has been sucking in x-rays from the hottest
things in the galaxy.
Literally.
X-rays are absorbed by Earth's atmosphere,
so Chandra uses four angled mirrors to look
at x-rays from exploded stars, clusters of
galaxies, and matter around black holes while
in orbit.
Scientists are using this data to learn what
happens around supernovae and the structure
of the black hole at the center of our Milky
Way galaxy.
This thing is tight, but not as tight as gamma
rays.
The Fermi Gamma Ray telescope was launched
in 2008 to probe the upper edge of the electromagnetic
spectrum, looking for gamma rays, the tiniest
and most energetic of all light.
Gamma radiation is put out by supermassive
black-hole systems, pulsars, and often makes
up cosmic rays; and studying these emanations
can teach us more about physics in the universe,
giving rise to new theories about how everything
fits together.
Gamma waves are superfast, often zooming by
in a fraction of a second, so Fermi looks
at one fifth of the sky at any given moment,
so it doesn't miss a burst!
There's a reason telescopes are everywhere
on Earth and in space.
They're like Earth's eyes and ears out there
-- pointing at the universe.
It's beautiful ain't it?
If you want to look beautiful too, try JackThreads.
JackThreads is the only place you need to
shop to find the best gear that won’t break
the bank.
They have stylists on call to make shopping
a no-brainer, plus tons of great brands to
select from.
You can get an additional 15% off of their
already pretty great prices by visiting JackThreads.com/DNews
and entering coupon code DNews at checkout.
You're helping us make DNews AND looking good
doing it.